Uh, let's see, why don't we go next?
We are taking calls.
(617) 830-4750.
Let's try the eight oh five area code isn't
eight Oh five a is that Pensacola, Florida
area?
Uh, no, that's um, California.
Oh, okay.
Maybe eight five zero is the Pensacola, Florida
area.
All right, go ahead.
Who's this?
Um, hello, my name is Christian [inaudible].
Great Christian from California.
What's on your mind today?
Um, I was wondering, do you believe that someone
can have a negative or critical takeaway of
your coverage of the Illinois Mar controversy
without accusing you of accusing Representative
Omar of antisemitism?
Oh sure.
Yeah.
Anybody.
I mean, listen, look at the email I get every
day.
People can have negative takeaways from every
single segment that I've ever done.
All right, cool.
Cause it just seems like you somewhat contradicted
that sentiment in your recent video about
the titling of the Sam Cedar Color.
You know, that color who misrepresented your
position on healthcare.
Right.
It seems it seems as it's in that video, you
sort of Straw man whose position on Ilana
Marr, he merely said that your take was a
bad tech, but then you went on, I like a two
minute rant about how people constantly accuse
you of accusing her of anti.
If you go back to the clip.
I certainly was not accusing that color of
making the allegation since he mentioned it
in the spur of the moment.
I'm just, you know, doing a show where I'm
reacting to what I hear that call or certainly
did not accuse me of that being my position,
but the color then did misrepresent my position
on healthcare and to give the example, if
the caller had even called Sam Cedar and said,
Hey, David Pakman says he's open to solutions
that get coverage to everyone that are not
necessarily medicare for all.
What do you think about that?
That's great because it's actually an accurate
representation of what I said.
Unfortunately he called and said something
like, I'm going from memory here.
Something like David Packman is, you know,
moving away from Medicare for all and is in
favor of the public option and it's like,
no, dude, I didn't say that.
Right, right, right.
I'm not defending his position on that.
I just wanted to clarify your position on
the Elon Omar controversy and how people can
maybe have negative sure.
Takeaways without necessarily misrepresenting
your position.
Any of my positions and have a negative takeaway
without misrepresenting it.
And that is what I call good faith, a disagreement.
But I'm, I'm glad that we've now clarified
my position on the caller's position, on my
position and that now your position will be
better informed.
Right, right, right.
All right, Christian, great to hear from you.
I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you.